The Joe Rogan Experience and then
Healthcare
like did you see did you see the thing I
posted a couple weeks ago about this
bill we got from when my Jill was with
the our middle son in San Diego visiting
a friend and he was sick so she had to
take him to an ER right like we don't
our doctor's not there right obviously
we live here so they did like regular
chemistry lab on him that's like about a
12 blood test and gave him like I don't
know 250 to 500 CC of IV fluid that was
it
that was it what do you think the bill
was
twelve hundred dollars
I don't remember it because I'd have to
look at the post I put up I think the
bill was 6 000 of which we owed 2 000.
that's insane that's that's problematic
that's a real problem yeah it might have
been more than that six thousand dollar
bill our insurance somehow picked up
maybe 3 500 we were stuck with 2500. now
juxtapose that with the following fact
fewer than 50 percent of Americans today
if given 24 hours can produce 2500 in
cash
Jesus Christ so when we say Health Care
is the leading cause of personal
bankruptcy
it's the first second third fourth fifth
cut like there's nothing else matters
besides health care when it comes to
personal bankruptcy
I mean this this does infuriate me to no
end like I sometimes think like is there
any other problem I would ever be
interested to devoting my full attention
to besides the problem I work on now
that's the only other problem that would
tempt me and you know what's interesting
too if that problem was really tackled
by by our government and they did it in
an efficient way
one of the ways they would have to do it
one of the ways it would have to address
it in order to be efficient would be to
encourage people to become metabolically
healthy
of course we have zero encouragement
zero in fact there's this is actually
the opposite there's there's
encouragement for people to have body
positivity and uh need to not be fat
phobic and to uh not fat shame you know
and if and and there's zero discussion
about healthy diets and vitamin
supplementation and the benefits of that
if we if if they just did like imagine
if the government was responsible for
our health care
and they realize hey guys guys guys we
got a real problem here we're spending
too much money and we're losing money
because
what if they're the amount of money that
they made was dependent upon the
percentage of money that was spent on
Health Care like imagine if politicians
if their salary depended on the like see
but I fear that that would still get
screwed up because then they would just
cut costs right like I feel like what if
that wasn't an option though
if we have to we have to cut costs this
is the problem right we're spending
we're probably up to ten thousand
dollars per capita
which is I mean we're actually probably
more than that we're probably twelve
thousand dollars fourteen thousand
dollars per capita so we're at two to
five x every other developed nation and
what we spend on health care but why and
we get worse outcomes okay so the big
reason comes down to made-up numbers
look at my ER example
the the blood test cost the actual cost
of ordering that blood test is twelve
dollars the bag of IV fluid is probably
38 dollars
so why do they inflate the cost so much
it's because they play a shell game with
the insurance company
so they say we negotiate different rates
with different insurance companies and
we're gonna we're gonna build up the
price enormously but we're going to
offer you a really big discount and
we're going to make you our preferred
network we're going to be your preferred
network and there's a you know a quid
pro quo here which is the price is
enormous but you don't actually have to
pay that much we're going to discount it
to you but if somebody comes in out of
network which we were right we were at a
network because you know we're probably
our network is optimized around being in
Austin and not in San Diego
um you're going to get screwed and of
course if you don't have insurance
forget about it you're paying the fake
money price especially if there's a real
injury oh yeah the real injury you need
surgery and you're not insured oh my God
the other thing is we don't have the
same laws around
um like drug pricing right so so drug
you know the the United States basically
subsidizes the rest of the world in drug
pricing so we in exchange for getting
first dibs on the best drugs we pay a
higher price for them
and other countries are basically not
going to pay that because you also have
better purchasing power so if you look
at Canada for example like the
government is buying the drugs not not
that not that not the payer right so
it's it's a it's a totally different
system and the challenge is no system is
going to be perfect but what really
bothers me about the discussion
is we're missing the point that there
are three variables that need to be
optimized around
and everybody just talks about their
favorite one
but you can't talk about one without
talking about the other two because if
you pull on one lever you gotta let up
on one of the other levers so the three
levers are
cost
how much does it cost to deliver this
care
the second is quality how good is the
and the third one is access
how many people fall through the cracks
so if you look at the United States
we're very good on quality when we
deliver care it's the best there's a
reason people come from all over the
world here when they need their cancer
surgery right we are certainly at or in
the you know at or above the best for
everything that would be done in
medicine
on cost we are absolutely the worst
there's literally no country that pays
more than we do for a given service wow
and on access we're horrible for a
developed Nation horrible right the
numbers like what is the difference
between like say United States and
Canada yeah
two and a half X I would bet wow
maybe 3x wow that's so crazy and that's
not like a third world country or
something like that right like that's
what's so so Canada is killing us in
cost they're killing us in Access
because everybody's covered yes we have
better quality so you have to so that's
that's the trade-off like right I mean I
do talk about how my mom is getting
largely veterinary medicine in Canada
I mean like her health care is horrible
as far as I'm concerned yeah totally
unacceptable many friends in Canada that
have complained no it's totally
unacceptable so they have bad care but
at least everybody gets it and it
doesn't cost you any money and it's is
it bad care because the Physicians are
not incentivized to provide better care
because they don't make as much money no
no no so first of all I mean at least I
don't know if I don't want to speak out
of school because I'm so far removed
from it but when I was growing up they
had introduced salary caps so Physicians
salaries were capped so when you hit
your cap you retire you stopped working
for the year so high earning surgeons
like would retire not retire would stop
working but in August because they'd hit
their set like let's say the salary cap
was 300 000 if you earn 300 000 by
August you weren't going to get paid
anymore so though they would just sit
down and sit out the rest of the year
and come back in January it would create
this real problem whether it was a
bottleneck shortage of dogs yeah yeah
but the bigger issue is just that the
governor government is in charge of what
gets done and what does not get done and
there's sort of shortages right so if
you like things that you and I take for
granted right if you tweaked your knee
at Jiu Jitsu tonight you go get an MRI
tomorrow
that doesn't happen in Canada in fact in
certain provinces it's illegal to have
private private clinics where you can go
pay out of your own pocket to get an MRI
expedite God it's illegal illegal I
think Ontario is one of those provinces
by the way really yep so Toronto in
Toronto I do not believe it is legal to
have private medical clinics where you
can pay out of pocket so this is where
when people say oh we should just be
like Canada I'm like no we should do
something Canada does we should have
Universal coverage and then have the
option and then you have the option to
bolt on yeah but would that be sort of
like public defenders versus a really
good attorney like because no I don't
think it would be I just suck yes of
course no I think I think one of the
things you have to do is provide primary
care and emergency services for free
because
that's where 90 of your care would be
delivered and is the problem that
because of these made up numbers you
discussed earlier that these people in
this country at least are accustomed to
charging these exorbitant fees like six
thousand dollars for a bag of IV oh yeah
like I mean I had I had my I got a
colonoscopy every three years so I had
my last one last this time a year ago
and
uh you know because I I it's funny that
one should have been covered I don't
remember the details on it but um
because I was over 45 at that point so
it's counted as a screening colonoscopy
but I've historically always had to pay
cash for my colonoscopies because I
started doing them when I was 40. and
the cash cost of getting a colonoscopy
at like one of the best guys in New York
City who I've always gone to is two
thousand dollars that's the fully loaded
cash cost that means that's covering the
facility fee the anesthesia his fee Etc
the one I got here in Austin where I did
it through insurance
the fee was six thousand dollars
I got the bill and you know my insurance
picked up maybe this is the one I'm
anyway my point is my cash out of pocket
was almost as bad as the cash I paid for
just a full up cash one it had a whole
bunch of made-up numbers I actually
called my gastroenterologist the guy who
did it I was like you got to walk me
through this because like I'm struggling
to understand these costs and he
couldn't really explain it
he's like I I mean
I don't know like I I don't really
understand it he's like but but you know
like everybody has sort of a different
amount you know it's like being at like
a Bazaar where it's like oh I have
special price for you today